[Music]
so
[Music]
okay so i just showered and curled my
hair
and got ready for the day honestly i
just really want to go explore big sur
and maybe film um as i go but i need to
upload a youtube video first and kind of
do the caption and thumbnail and
everything and also really need to fill
my water so
i'm gonna go try to find a place with
wi-fi and we'll go from there okay i
don't know if i'm supposed to park here
but i'm gonna do it anyway
[Music]
so i just found a place to get wi-fi
i've been here many times before and as
soon as i signed in
i got a critical security alert from
google that everything got signed out
and someone had access to my account
which sucks totally freaks me out it's
never happened to me before
um hopefully it's not too late and
someone has access to my stuff but i
just changed all my passwords for my
important stuff and i uh
immediately downloaded a vpn service so
i probably should have done that a long
time ago but
fingers crossed this does not come back
to bite me
but yeah that's something you deal with
on the road and probably something i
should have addressed sooner getting a
vpn just to protect your data because i
use a lot of public wi-fi
i
finally figured out the vpn thing and
also was able to upload my youtube video
but it's now 2 30 p.m so that took a lot
more time than i anticipated
[Music]
so i'm back in my favorite place and the
light's starting to get good i have to
do a shoot today um i actually have 24
hours to shoot edit and post it so
kind of waited to the last minute on
this one
i was focused on photography this day so
i didn't take much video but i did catch
this sunset clip for you
and even though i love this place after
three weeks of facing around big sur i
decided it was time to head east toward
the sierras
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
every year for the past four years i've
left the pacific northwest to chase
warmer weather usually i head to
california then arizona and onto utah as
the weather gets warmer before looping
up through wyoming and montana and back
through oregon and up to washington
last year i went counter-clockwise and
spent the fall in wyoming then utah and
colorado before beelining straight to
arizona when the snowstorms moved in
if you had asked me this past fall about
the upcoming winter i would have told
you i was pretty serious about booking a
two to three month long airbnb some
place over the winter months i was just
craving routine and i don't know just
stability but when i came back from
europe something shifted i fell in love
with the road again and this year i'm
back to the usual rotation south and
there's a comforting sense of
familiarity to it that just feels like
home
[Music]
[Music]
it's pretty chilly tonight so i got the
comforter and the wool blanket and
definitely have the heater on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've been to alabama hills many times
before but this was my first time
bringing the van since i've had the
heater installed
in the past i've tent camped i've slept
in the back of my suv and i've also
looked out on this landscape from the
summit of mount whitney at sunrise on my
final day of the john muir trail and i
gotta say shooting sunrise and seeing
these views and then stepping into a
toasty warm van to make a hot cup of
coffee and snuggle back into bed it was
a whole new experience
for me it was heaven on earth
the weather forecast said a storm was
moving in that day which is probably why
i had such an epic sunrise but i didn't
want to stick around to see if i got
stuck so i headed further south and met
up with nathaniel in the desert
we spent two weeks looking after two
really cute cats and a beautiful home
near san diego
hey teddy
excuse me excuse me
it looks so good
teddy what are you doing over there
we spent a lot of time cooking and
lounging and we also met up with our
friend quinn who happened to be staying
in an airbnb just a couple blocks away
from where we were we pretty much just
took it easy and laid low for a while
and we even took up tennis which we are
both really really bad at but we just
got bored one day and went to a sporting
goods store and bought tennis rackets
and it's actually pretty fun being
terrible and totally new at something
we've been finding tennis courts all
along our routes to try and play but
yeah like i said we have a lot to learn
after the new year we headed back into
the desert
[Music]
there's always a part of me that craves
the desert
i think it's the desolation and absence
of people
you have space to hear the wind and
breathe deep and get lost down lonely
dusty roads
but sooner or later there's always the
question of loneliness i'd say i'm
pretty lucky because nathaniel and i
often travel together these days and
truthfully it's pretty rare to be in a
place for very long before someone in
the photography or road life community
rolls through
a lot of us tend to gravitate toward the
same beautiful places
[Music]
i also have avocados lime cilantro
cheese
sour cream
cheese okay
oh
[Music]
if we're gonna grill our burritos
oh
[Music]
i'm so freaking ready
[Music]
[Music]
after a few weeks in southern california
i headed someplace new that i've always
wanted to explore
the land of enchantment
[Music]
i'll see you guys out here in the next
one and as always thanks for being here
[Music]
okay that cannot stay in the van
oh my god
wow this is my super sexy
outfit i was
in bed
and a spider crawled up next to me on
the duvet i caught it and now i gotta go
outside
and dump it and pray to god that it
doesn't come back because i hate spiders
dude do you have family in here because
if you do
i'm gonna have to ask you
to kindly
leave
you